for quick-reaction is the great one life
liberty of the levin we call mark levin
the great one is well those you know
mark it really comes down to the
arguments that were made by Schumer and
Pelosi I don't mean to be sarcastic but
it looked like a Saturday Night Live
opening skit but especially considering
Chuck Schumer in particular his past
support Obama support Hillary's support
Biden's support for barriers in a wall
around in 2006 and thirteen but they're
they're saying that this is a
manufactured crisis and they are saying
that they're upset about the delayed
checks to furloughed federal government
employees which I am sympathetic towards
but the president is making the case
that we have Americans being victims of
crime homicide sexual assault other
violent assaults that we have all right
trafficking that we have that's going
across the border human trafficking drug
trafficking to me it's about life and
death or inconvenience this is not
manufactured you can't tell the son of
officers saying that this is a
manufactured crisis this is a real
life-and-death situation for many
American families and I wanted to get
your reaction to tonight of all the
president gave an outstanding speech was
concise it was compassionate and truly
compassionate he provided the context
both in terms of what's going on in the
border the expense which is de minimis
and who's really responsible I'll let's
keep a few things in mind when you watch
Schumer in policy there are pathological
liars they've been in Congress over half
a century what the hell have they done
about the border nothing they're part of
the scam artists they get amnesty
legalization citizenship and never
secure the border just spend billions
and trillions more more debt more
deficits on the redistribution of wealth
on two hundred billion dollars a year on
illegal aliens
one more time they fooled Reagan a full
Bush 41 a full Bush 43 but they're not
gonna fool Donald Trump who start with
tougher than Pelosi and Schumer let me
point out a few things these two and the
rest of them are never forced to explain
their flip-flop where they were for
border security they voted to authorize
walls they voted to fund some of the
walls and now all of a sudden it's
immoral
you know what's immoral when everybody
talks about those government employees
who will be temporarily in convinced who
will get their money back but nobody
talks about the unskilled low-skilled
American worker who has to compete with
people from Guatemala from Honduras from
Mexico from south of the border who come
into this country illegally nobody talks
about the big corporations like
hewlett-packard and Boeing at Disney and
others where part of the scam artist
operation - one illegal aliens in this
country nobody talks about the fact that
destroying our immigration system these
Democrat cities sanctuary cities these
Democrat states sanctuary states where
the citizens are treated as second-class
citizens and the taxpayers have to cough
up the money for what let me explain
what this is about power Democrat Party
power Democrat Party before country
there's an excellent piece and of all
places the Atlantic a left-wing site
written by a guy by the name of Peter
Burkhardt a liberal and he says between
2008 and 26 the Democrats became more
and more confident that the country's
growing Latino population gave the party
in lecto edge so they switched salon
which is a left-wing site they declared
after Obama's 2008 when if that pattern
continues with the Latino vote the GOP
is doomed for 40 years wandering in the
desert and he goes on to explain this is
a liberal on a liberal site that is
exactly what's going on
notice Pelosi and Schumer didn't talk
about the American worker notice they
didn't talk about the communities on the
border that are suffering notice they
never talk about law and order because
they hate law enforcement they never
talk about the overwhelming costs
involved in health care the overwhelming
costs involved in our public schools
localities and states they're barely
reimbursed for this pay more we the
American taxpayer the American citizen
we take it in the neck one other thing
the Democrat plan
form in 2008 read it let me ask you the
Democrat platform in 2008 basically
supports virtually everything the
Republican President of the United
States said today the American people
haven't changed the Republican Party
hasn't changed the Democrats for
political reasons and power reasons
they've changed and they want to drag us
all up that lift with Mark that's a
great point and we we played their past
statements many times on this program I
know you played it on your radio show
and life liberty and Levin I want to get
into the issue of legality and I saw a
post that you made and that is that the
President as the commander-in-chief has
the right to declare a national
emergency which would then therefore
give him the funds obviously it would
end up in the courts they go judge
shopping they printed in a court in
California so go to the Ninth Circuit I
want to talk about the legality of that
and also as the commander in chief
constitutionally this is your wheelhouse
wouldn't he have the ability to say that
this is a national security issue and as
such be able to appropriate funds from
the Defense Department as well those
here as usual know where Bragg just fact
it's left to me to straighten out all
these phony experts on cable and network
TV who have law degrees and pretend they
know something it's called the national
emergency a mark I agree and basically
Congress passed this to tighten to limit
what a president could do unilaterally
and there's a provision in the statute
it's a statute so it's not the president
acting unconstitutionally and in this
statute if Congress wants to reverse or
halt what the president is doing
unilaterally it takes a joint resolution
of the House and Senate a majority vote
of both so there is a check that's
number one number two these powers
essentially in different iterations in
the past different laws in 20 seconds
more go back before Abraham Lincoln they
have been exercised multiple times I
would tell the bush she never trumpets
they were exercised multiple times by
george w bush mark what we gonna have to
let it go there
Mark Levine the great one life liberty
and Levin number one shown in slot
Sunday night's 10:00 Eastern here on the
Fox News Channel